شكرا صاحب سمو صاحب السمو الملكي ولي عهد
المملكه العربيه السعوديه الامير محمد بن
سلمان اصحاب الجلاله والسمو والفخامه
والسياده معالي الامين العام للجامعه
الدول العربيه الشكر اولا للمملكه العربيه
السعوديه قياده وشعبا على احتضانها قاده
العرب على ارضها المباركه وقد جاؤوا
حاملين فيها امال شعوبهم والامهم
ومطلعين الى تحقيق غدا افضل لهم في ظل
رئاسه المملكه للدوره الحاليه للقمه
والشكر موصول ايضا الى الجزائر الشقيقه
على كل الجهود التي بذلتها خلال تراسها
الدوره السابقه
من الجزائر التي عملت بثبات وهدوء لم
الشمل الى المملكه العربيه السعوديه حاضنه
العرب كل العرب والتي نثق بحكمه القيادتها
وقدرتها على اعاده وصل منقطع بين اخوه
يجمعهم اكثر بكثير مما يفرقهم
اسمحوا لي ان اسمي هذه القمه قمه تضمير
الجراح حيث سبق انعقادها اتفاقا لاعاده
العلاقات الى طبيعتها بين المملكه العربيه
السعوديه والجمهوريه الاسلاميه الايرانيه
وايضا تثمين عوده الشقيقه الثوريه الى
القيام بدورها كاملا في جامعه الدول
العربيه
المشكلات والقضايا العربيه نعرفها جميعا
من ماسك من ماساه فلسطين الى اليمن ومؤخرا
الى وضع المؤسف في السودان ولكن انا اريد
ان اتحدث عن وطني لبنان الذي يستمر في
معاناته من ازمات متعدده ارحب بفقلها على
الشعب اللبناني الذي يعيش سنوات سنوات
عجاف يعاني فيها يوميا ما يعانيه من فقدان
المقومات الاساسيه المعنويه والمديه التي
تمكنه من الصمود
وقد ازدادت هذه الحاله تعقيدا بشغور سده
الرئاسه الجمهوريه وتعذر انتخاب رئيس جديد
اضافه الى ان لبنان لم يتوانى يوما عن فتح
ابوابه امام اخواننا النازحين السوريين
ايمانا باخوه الشعبين وتقدم الاعتبارات
الانسانيه على ما عداها
لكن طول امد الازمه وتعثر معالجتها وتزايد
اعداد النازحين بشكل كبير يجعل من ازمه
النزوح اكبر من طاقه لبنان على التحمل لا
من حيث بناه تحتيه ولا من حيث التاشيرات
الاجتماعيه والارتدادات السياسيه في
الداخل ولا من حيث الحق الطبيعي لهؤلاء
النازحين بالعوده الى مدنهم وقراهم هي
عوده لا يمكن ان تتحقق اذا لم تتضافر
الجهود العربيه مع مؤازره من المجتمع
الدولي وبالتواصل والحوار مع الشقيقه
السوريه في اطار موقف عربي جامع عبر
مشاريع بناء وانعاش للمناطق المهدمه لوضع
خارطه الطريق لعوده الاخوه السوريين الى
ديارهم
في هذا في هذا اللقاء لابد من تاكيد
احترامي لبنان لكافه القرارات الدوليه
المتتاليه الصادره عن مجلس الامن الدولي
وقرارات الجامعه العربيه وميثاقها
والالتزام بتنفيذ منتدى درجاتها وانا اؤكد
ايضا باسمي كل لبنان احترام مصالح الدول
الشقيقه وسيادتها وامنها الاجتماعي
والسياسي ومحاربه تصدير الممنوعات اليها
وكل ما يسيء الى الاستقرار فيها هو التزام
التزام ثابت ينبع من احساس بالمسؤوليه
تجاه اشقائنا ومن حرصنا على امنهم
وسلامتهم وصفاء العلاقات الاخويه معهم
وصدقها
صاحب السموم من استطاع نقل المملكه
العربيه السعوديه وشبابها الى المواقع
القياديه والرياديه التي وصلوا اليها
وتحويل المملكه الى بلد منتج بكل مليء
كلمه من معناه في فتره قصيره ليس صعبا
عليه ان يكون العضد لاشقائه في لبنان ومن
هنا فانا اطلع الى رعايه المملكه ولفتتها
الاخويه تجاه بلدي لبنان ليتمكن من النهوض
من جديد ختاما اكرر شكر لبنان للدول
الشقيقه وخاصه اعضاء التعاون الخليجي على
اتاحه فرص عمل للبنانيين على اراضيها وضمن
مؤسساتها الخاصه والعامه فلولا هذه
الرعايه لكان وضعه لبنان المالي
والاقتصادي والاجتماعي اشد قساوه والى من
ولابد لي ايضا من هنا عن هذا المنبر ان
اشكر جمهوريه العراقيه على ما تقدمه دائما
من اجل لبنان وكم نتمنى من الاخوه العرب
عودتهم سريعا جميعا الى لبنان في هذا
الصيف وبعد قال تعالى في كتابه العزيز
سنشد وعضدك باخيك صدق الله العظيم فشدوا
ايها الاصدقاء عدد لبنان الذي سيبقى
برعايتكم وكما عهدتموه جامعا للعرب
والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
لمتابعه المزيد الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات